[Música]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los iba a dar una vuelta al mundo de
la mano de nuestra red de periodistas
soy herminia Fernández por Andrés
espinal comenzamos con un reporte sobre
la base por el control de Back Mode en
Ucrania en estas ciudades estratégica
dlc del país las fuerzas supranianas se
aferran a pesar de la ofensiva rusa un
equipo de nuestra cadena hermana France
dos fue al frente de batalla y acompañó
a soldados ucranianos aquí la historia
es un francotirador escondido en un
edificio de bacmut solo lo acompaña su
arma
el objetivo ruso está 1,2 kilómetros de
distancia
se prepara para otra misión está a punto
de salir con sus hombres a patrullar la
zona en una operación de reconocimiento
avanzan hacia donde se escuchan las
explosiones de los proyectiles la
situación se ha vuelto más tensa en los
últimos días el centro de bacmut es
ahora una ciudad fantasma
su misión es delicada y peligrosa el
pelotón de reconocimiento debe rastrear
objetivos rusos para informar a las
tropas ucranianas que están más atrás el
panorama es confuso
refugiado unas horas después de su
operación el ex legionario que pasó
cinco años en Francia explica la
situación militar Hablamos
ahora mismo diría que al menos el 50% de
la ciudad está tomada por los rusos
su avance continua
el consumidor
la situación es muy dura muy complicada
los ataques y asaltos rusos continúan
constantemente continúan los ataques los
disparos de todos los calibres
pero las fuerzas ucranianas siguen
resistiendo nuestro equipo pudo visitar
una de sus posiciones de artillería A
las afueras de backmuto Caminando un
kilómetro por rutas alternas para llegar
aquí y evitando espacios abiertos ambos
bandos disparan proyectiles
alguna de nuestras fuerzas siguen en el
centro de la ciudad
hemos venido a reconquistar nuestra
tierra no entregarnos
están esperando las coordenadas de un
nuevo objetivo después de intercambiar
disparos todo el día siguen atentos para
la contraofensiva desde hace semanas y
esperan que los suministros de armas y
equipos sean suficientes
los exóticos platos en los que se
mezclan todo tipo de especias con
verduras frescas legumbres y una gran
variedad de carnes y pescados han hecho
de la cocina libanesa un referente de la
gastronomía mundial sin embargo la
profunda crisis económica que vive en
Líbano está cambiando la dieta
tradicional de los libaneses que ahora
se alimentan con productos de bajo costo
ethel bonet y Diego Ibarra nos cuentan
más
durante más de 30 años en su programa de
cocina el chef antuán ha sido fiel a las
recetas tradicionales de la cocina
libanesa reconocidan todo el mundo ahora
sustituye sus platos con ingredientes
más económicos en carne roja para poder
adoptarlos a los tratados bolsillos de
las familias de vanesas
decidí cambiar mis recetas siempre
utilizaba carne de res pollo pescado
blanco o salmón pero con el colapso
económico la carne más barata que era la
vacuna se ha vuelto un producto de lujo
los consejos y secretos de cocina sirven
de inspiración a mujeres como josefing
para poder sobrevivir alepreinflación de
los productos alimenticios con su sueldo
en la devaluada libre libanesa le
alcanza para comprar los productos
básicos Así que ha dejado cocinar este
guiso con caldo casero de carne que
sustituye por pasta de tomate
concentrado y el arroz lo acompaña con
verduras y papas antes no cocinábamos
así en el Líbano tengo dos hijos y no
puedo darles una dieta sana y
equilibrada como la que solíamos tener
estoy preocupada por su crecimiento y
concentración
la decisión del gobierno quitar los
subsidios a las importaciones de bienes
básicos de alimentos por la crisis
económica también afectado a la cadena
de distribución En esta carnicería la
venta carne roja ha caído alrededor de
un 70% porque los precios se han
quintoplicado el
estamos comprando un 20% menos de lo que
adquiríamos cuando la carne era
subsidiada y las ventas a restaurantes
supermercados y clientes son muy bajas
la hiperinflación en la caída de las
importaciones no son los únicos
problemas que afectan a los bienes de
consumo a husein consultor de
exportaciones le preocupa que haya
bajado la calidad de las mercancías
alimentarias ya no importamos carne roja
de Australia ni lácteos europeos
nuestros mercados son ahora el Turco o
Países Árabes que venden más barato pero
de peor calidad conocida como la
coherente medio por Su riqueza y
variedad de alimentos la cocina libanesa
se ha hecho Popular en todo el mundo
pero la crisis económica está poniendo
en peligro siglos de tradición de la
buena comida libanesa
la selección femenina de fútbol de
Francia terminó su primera concentración
bajo las órdenes de herbert el nuevo
director técnico el resultado dos
victorias en partidos amistosos contra
Colombia y Canadá inicia así una nueva
era tras semanas de crisis en medio de
polémicas que se saldaron con la salida
del entrenadora
corindiacreb viajarán a Australia y a
Nueva Zelanda Con un objetivo en la
mirax ganar un primer título mundial
Natalia Ruiz y cedric Ferreira
estuvieron con las jugadoras
aquí encontrar el justo medio entre
acelerar y calmar por ratos tomarse su
tiempo y esperar por los desplazamientos
de sus compañeras
al final estuvo muy bien felicitaciones
desde su llegada a impuesto su sello
combinar exigencia y alentar el ex
entrenador de Arabia Saudita que logró
Con este equipo una histórica Victoria
ante Argentina en el mundial de fútbol
de Qatar trajo consigo nuevos Aires y
reitera cuán Contento está de haber sido
elegido en este nuevo cargo
me siento muy a gusto y es una gran
suerte para mí el estar aquí
las francesas salen de un periodo
difícil que terminó con la renuncia de
varias jugadoras emblemáticas tras
oponerse al método de cojín Jack quien
dirigía al equipo desde 2017 en apenas
unos días la complicidad entre el doble
campeón de la Copa africana de Naciones
y las jugadoras salta a la vista
tiene mucho conocimiento de lo que
sucede en otros países tiene lo vivido y
la experiencia
hablamos mucho con él es alguien muy
abierto
las reivindicaciones de las jugadoras
que se rebelaron fueron escuchadas ahora
la selección cuenta con un staff más
amplio y abierto al diálogo seis
personas conforman el cuerpo técnico de
joanalicemos ya sea en las sesiones lo
que plantean los ejercicios sentimos un
cambio directamente es un cambio
positivo para nosotras es de alto nivel
hay que decir la verdad cuando vemos
grandes equipos los que ganan
campeonatos a nivel europeo copas del
mundo todos tienen un amplio staff esta
nueva era comienza con el pie derecho
con dos victorias en partidos amistosos
contra Colombia y Canadá Hace unos días
su preparación para el mundial de fútbol
en Australia y Nueva Zelanda ya aprendió
motores el objetivo para este verano es
claro y manifiesto dar al fútbol
femenino francés su primer título
mundial
la Inteligencia artificial adquiere un
poder cada vez más vertiginoso en su
creación de imágenes de video poder que
a veces es muy inquietante por su
capacidad de engañarnos o de manipular
la información pero también tiene un
poder artístico el arte visual fuente de
invención y evasión un mundo irreal en
el que nuestros colegas Bryan Queen y
Montes Francis nos sumergen a
continuación
son imágenes digitales que parecen
reales la fachada de un edificio cae
para regular una figura humana gigante
una calabaza gigante rodando por las
calles de París
[Música]
por supuesto nada de esto es real todo
es virtual un vistazo a un mundo
imaginario que arrasa en las redes
sociales
de lonílico a lo pesadillasco
es el trabajo artistas digitales como el
Owen la Belén a quien vemos aquí
lanzando una crepe sobre la Pirámide del
Loop
una proeza culinaria lograda con la
ayuda de una pantalla verde enrollable
una pirámide de papel y algunos crepes
sacrificados
los monumentos de París pasamos por
delante de ellos todo el tiempo cruzamos
los puentes pero ver un poco de fantasía
en un lugar que conocemos también Me
parece increíble
mientras que algunos artistas digitales
acaban de empezar otros ya tienen
carreras consolidadas detrás de esta
baguette abriéndose paso por burdeos o
de estos peces escapando del Museo de
encontrarán un estadounidense viviendo
en Francia grandes marcas y artistas han
encargado su trabajo para llenar sus
redes sociales para una famosa estilista
transforma bolsos en automóviles y para
la cantante Ángel convierte una Estación
de metro en un túnel de montaña rusa
[Música]
las redes sociales son como un jardín
hay que regarlas todos los días tienes
que asegurarte de que siempre aparezca
contenido para que la gente que te sigue
sigue interesada e inspirada para que
hagas ruido aunque sean cortos Hay
momentos en los que algo de 10 segundos
puede tener un gran impacto artístico o
emocional
sólo duran segundos son como poemas
cortos vistos cientos de miles de veces
hasta aquí corresponsales de la semana
hoy desde la feria del libro de Bogotá
siga con más información en France 24 y
France 24.com